[Music]
[Applause]
is the Monday Morning Quarterback Albert
Breer back on the program give me the
state of uh these two teams that played
last night let's start with the Raiders
what condition are they in right
now you know they're sort of in this in
between Dan because they did these
things you know when Dave Ziggler and
Josh McDaniels got there um you know a
year and a half ago that really seemed
targeted on taking advantage of the
roster that they had and going and
getting Devonte Adams and bringing
Chandler Jones in and you know there are
players in that roster again that are in
the prime of their careers Max Crosby
Colton Miller Josh Jacobs
so um you know I I think the Raiders
have to go into today with you know an
honest mindset and try to look at it and
say okay where are we and where are we
going um you know after the way Jimmy's
played like I don't know where they are
a quarterback um you know certainly I
don't think Jimmy's played well enough
for them not to be looking hard at
taking one um in the spring um and you
know if you're starting over a
quarterback where does that leave you
with the rest of your stars you know
again like it's not a bad roster it does
have holes though and you got a lot of
guys that are right in the prime of
their careers and so you know the
question is how do you get that
quarterback position solved to either
leverage what's left with the group of
players you have or um you know whether
or not you make the decision to start
over with someone new do the Raiders
sell
today I I don't think it was their
intention going into the weekend I know
it wasn't their intention to move
Devonte Adams here's what I do know um
the Stefon digs thing are you familiar
with how that happened three years ago
like what actually prompted
that do you remember no was actually a
tweet all right he tweeted something
about and I can't remember exactly what
it was but it pointed to him not being
happy with a situation in Minnesota no
one thought he was was getting traded at
that point well you know Brandon being
the bills general manager saw the Tweet
picked up the phone called Rick
Spielman and I think 10 hours later the
trade happened you know so I'm telling
I'm telling you that story because they
may not have an intention to trade
Devonte Adams but there are going to be
general managers that saw Devonte Adams
reaction on the sideline yesterday and
his reaction in the locker room
yesterday and I actually think like if
you look at it he looked like a good guy
who's just frustrated that's my
perception like watching him um you know
and knowing what I know about him I mean
if you're a team that needs a receiver
aren't you gonna call up aren't you
gonna like make that phone call today so
they may not have an intention of
trading Devonte Adams but does somebody
put something in front of them that they
can't say no to today I think it's
creates an interesting Dynamic that's
not all that unlike what happened with
Stefon Diggs um three years ago where
are the Lions right now I'm they look
like a Powerhouse I mean if you want to
throw the Ravens game which was I mean a
disaster for them in just about every
way possible um you know like they have
legitimately I I was saying this a
couple weeks ago like they don't look
like a Cinderella I know everybody wants
to turn them into this cute Cinderella
Story they operate like a pop Powerhouse
they operate with strengths on the
strength on the lines of scrimmage they
operate with Playmakers on offense St
Brown and Gibbs and I think Jameson
Williams will get there they got
Playmakers at linebacker they got guys
in the back end that look like they can
really play I mean it's just um it it it
looks like a team that you know maybe we
should be talking about them with the
Niners and the Eagles in the NFC you
know I I think you know if you want to
look at the two teams really that have
kind of stepped up into that Arena you
know because I think coming into the
year we figured it maybe it' be the
Eagles and Niners and everybody else and
a depleted NFC if there are two teams
that I think have sort of jumped up into
that group one would be Detroit the
other would be
Seattle does anybody of note get moved
today so like I it's hard to predict
these things right um
because I don't know that the biggest
stars are actively being shopped in fact
I'm I'm sure they're not being shopped
you know but again these phone calls can
happen and we know Carolina is in Cell
mode we know Minnesota is in Cell mode
we know Denver is in Cell mode so the
Panthers with Brian Burns their contract
negotiations have gone nowhere in fact
there's been almost no communication
since week one um between the sides he's
in a contract year they were offered two
first rounders and a third rounder by
the Rams last year they turned it down
they want Brian Burns and their football
team going forward they can franchise
him after the year and trade him then if
they want to um they could pay him
although it doesn't seem like they're
willing to go into the neighborhood
Burns wants to be in to get there so if
somebody comes and offers them the Rams
deal again do they do it that'd be one
um another be denil hunter in Minnesota
if somebody comes along and offers them
a top 50 or 60 pick which hasn't
happened yet but if somebody offers them
that he's 29 years old he's a free agent
he may not be on the team past the next
10 games your quarterback is hurt do you
do it he'd be another one and then to me
the biggest name would be out in Denver
Denver's gonna listen on everybody they
need picks so they'll listen on Jerry
Judy they'll listen on courland Sutton
they'll listen on Josie juel they'll
listen on Justin
Simmons what if somebody offers a
Godfather pack for Patrick ctan they
have no intention of moving but what if
somebody says we'll offer you more than
the Jaguars got for Jaylen Ramsey in
2019 which was two ones and a four do
they at least think about it then so
that would be another big name to watch
and then of course I mean you could go
to your saquan Barkley you know in New
York you could go to your Derrik Henry
in in in Tennessee those guys are both
in contract years the Giants and Titans
are more than willing to listen on all
of their pending unrestricted free
agents I don't think those teams intend
to move those guys but again you never
know what somebody could come along and
offer when the deadline is there he's
Albert Breer the Monday Morning
Quarterback if Kyler Murray is healthy
will he start for the
Cardinals I think they're GNA play him
yeah like I think I think they want to
my what I've heard is that they want to
um they want to gather information on
him and you know I know there are a lot
of people out there that um think that
the Cardinals are very focused on
getting Caleb Williams or Drake May um I
do think that they want to have like a a
full understanding of what they've got
in house and Kyler Murray so that means
playing him and that means seeing what
you've got and either he plays great and
he plays he plays well enough to move
you off of the first or second pick or
he doesn't and then the decision's made
and you're moving on after this year and
you're taking either the USC quarterback
of the North Carolina quarterback but if
you're Atlanta yeah wouldn't you reach
out and just say well so here's the
here's the problem though Dan right like
I think that makes sense right it makes
sense like could Minnesota or Atlanta or
one of these teams look at it and say
yeah you know what we take on Kyler
Murray the problem is that you you're
not trading for the player you're
trading for the contract yeah and like
if you are Arthur Smith and Terry font
now know you're now in year three in
Atlanta right how many more years are
you going to get one more two maybe one
more after this this year one yeah
right right so if you trade for that
contract you're tying your job security
to Kyler Murray but they have a better
chance of winning and keeping their job
with Kyler Murray than they do Desmond
Ritter right but then that doesn't that
take you out of play for a quarterback
in April but you won't need one if you
get Kyler Murray if you you know like
are you sure are you sure he's gonna
play that well like that's the thing is
like what the what the Falcons have told
us with their what the Falcons have told
us with their actions Dan is but they
have the 19th pick right now Albert
they're not but but but they're not
gonna they didn't I mean they're not
gonna go all what the Falcons have told
us with their actions is they're not
going to go all in on a quarterback
until they are 100% sold that's the guy
you can argue whether it's right or
wrong but they're not going to do it
until they are 100% sold that they've
got the guy they feel like they're they
can coach it well enough they can put
good enough players in the roster to
tread water until they get there right
sort of like I don't know like this is
different but Andy Reid we talked about
that before where they took Alex Smith
and they tread water until they got to
Patrick Mahomes right they feel like
they can tread water until they find a
guy they're really willing to go all in
on I just I think the problem with Kyler
Murray right now isn't the player it's
the contract and I think if you with
ownership with job all that different
stuff like with everything that comes
with giving a guy a $50 million a year
contract or 46 or 47 whatever it is I
think it's
46 like you are tying if you are quac ad
doam Mena or Kevin oconnell in Minnesota
or you're Arthur Smith or Terry fono in
Atlanta you are tying your job security
to Kyler Murray if you trade for him
like would you feel comfortable doing
that if I'm sold on Kyler Murray I don't
want Kyler Murray but if I think Kyler
Murray in Atlanta right and and and with
that they have skill position players
and Desmond Ritter doesn't appear to be
the quarterback you're going to probably
get fired because Desmond Ritter is not
the quarterback right but you didn't
sell out on Desmond Ritter that's the
thing Desmond Ritter's making nothing
you can you can you can bench but you
got an 80-year old owner all of these
owners are in their mid 7s or up you
know in the 80s they all they don't want
to be like let's try it again you know
yeah I know and I I think the hard thing
is like look like everything with the
quarterbacks is context right like Jared
Goff wasn't good enough for the Rams
okay Jared gof got the Rams to a Super
Bowl but the Rams decided you know what
at that price it's not worth it if we're
g to spend that much on a quarterback we
need to level up so they go and they get
Matthew Stafford they won a Super Bowl
right decision right like you win that
you you lift up Lombardi you made the
right
call jarro Goff goes to Detroit in a
different context right like he's not
the Savior and a lot of the money is off
of his contract now you know what he
just fine right it's all context and so
if you are buying Kyler Murray on Jimmy
garoppolo's contract or Derek Carr's
contract that's much different than
trading for his contract as it is right
now true because now if you if you trade
for his contract as it is right now well
because of the guaranteed money you're
tying yourself to the guy for multiple
years and eventually you have to is that
going to be good enough like like when
it comes down to it when you're trying
to get yourself over the top is that is
that going to be good enough or are you
going to turn yourself into the 45 win
NBA team that's paying a bunch of tier
two stars too much money and can't get
past Yannis you know can't get past like
the Knicks right like they like like do
you want to be the like and that's
that's that's the thing that's what
happens with these teams like when you
pay a quarterback when you pay a b
quarterback with an a contract there's a
lot of evidence that shows us in recent
years at least that that puts you in a
place where you're like that 45 win NBA
team the 49ers got a lot of cap room
they they surprised us with mcaffrey the
trade deadline Debo's hurt why don't
would would the Raiders make a trade
with the
ners if I don't know see see but that's
so far down the list of their needs
don't you think I mean like the skill
offensive skill is not their problem
right but that's a luxury
item okay if you're Kansas City it is
but it it is but how much are you g to
get him on the field you know what I
mean like if you're the Niners like it's
like you got KD you got auk who you're
gonna have to pay you've got Debo Samuel
you have Christian mcaffrey I mean if
I'm the ners and I'm taking a big swing
like if I want to take a really big
swing then you go for Burns Burns or
ceran right oh ctan yes yes you know
what I mean like but why would Shawn
Payton come into a situation with a
quarterback who's on the back end of his
career and Shawn is you know wants to
show that he can win without Drew Brees
right now you're going to get rid of all
the rece you know all the
receivers the reason you would do that
is if you've decided that you're going
to move on from that quarterback oh okay
do you think that they would move on
from if you're resetting well if they
made if they're looking at it because
the interesting thing about about
Russell's contract a Shawn didn't
negotiate it so Shawn doesn't so if it
looks like a bad contract well Sean can
say well that's not my contract right
like I didn't do that contract with him
they could the the interesting thing
about Russell's contract is it would be
very expensive for them to get it out of
it after this year like I think they'd
have to pay it's like a$ 37 million
they'd have to pay like or $39 million
of future money and guarantees to get
out of it right but it's almost as
expensive to get out of it the year
after so in other words if you bail
after this year you're you're
effectively gonna have to pay like a$ 39
million buyout to get out of the
contract if you but but if you wait
until next year right you're going to
have to pay a $37 million buyout to get
out of it after 24 so it's kind of like
all right well do we just bite the
bullet now you know if you don't think
he's that player and I don't think he's
been the problem either but it's also
like you only have so long to build so
if you're if you're sea do you look at
it and say keeping Russell here is
kicking the can down the road we need to
pull the Band-Aid off and if you're
pulling the bandaid off don't you look
at your roster completely different then
and don't you say to yourself you know
what we got to go and build some draft
Capital because remember they were
cleaned out by both the Russell Wilson
trade and the Shawn Payton trade they
need
picks great to talk to you as always
Albert thank you all right great thanks
Dan I appreciate it Albert Breer the
Monday Morning Quarterback